Did you know
that an estimated 10 million children
in the United States
see their fathers less than once a month?
Research tells us what happens
to boys and girls without dads
or stable father figures in their lives.
Poverty rates double,
emotional and behavioral
health issues increase,
high school dropout rates increase,
as do crime and prison rates.
And I was no different.
I grew up in Georgia without my father.
My mother raised me.
And let me tell you
something about my mom.
Every day before school, she would look
me in the eyes and say to me,
"You are tall, dark and handsome."
(Laughter)
(Applause)
"And you can do anything
you want in this world
if you put your mind to it."
But I didn't believe her.
I struggled.
Behavioral issues,
substance abuse issues,
suicidal ideation.
I blamed myself
for my father being absent.
I remember I was in college.
In my room by myself.
"God, you have to help me use my pain."
So I went on a journey to find my father.
And what I found was shocking.
My father had been experiencing an issue
that he needed help in overcoming.
He was experiencing his own pain.
His absence was not my fault.
And in a way, not his fault.
Then I thought to myself,
what if my father would have had
a caring group of neighbors
to support him?
It would have made a difference
for the both of us.
Now, there's a lot of reasons that keep
fathers separated from their children.
There are the ones
you might think of right away,
like estrangement from a mother,
substance abuse, sickness
and incarceration.
But the reasons that don't get
talked about enough
are the ones that exacerbate the problem.
Those are the emotions
we don't talk about enough.
I'm talking about shame.
Guilt.
And embarrassment.
These emotions can cause so much harm
beyond the absence.
Ben was a 32-year-old father
at an agency that I run
called Fathers’ UpLift,
where we help fathers love,
forgive and heal.
And in doing so,
they learn to find the beauty
in the pain they've experienced.
Now one might ask,
how can pain be beautiful?
At Fathers' UpLift, we believe
that pain gives you character,
strength and courage.
More importantly, there is a mystery
on the other side of pain.
For the population we work with,
that mystery is a father's child.
The warm embrace with your child
on the other side of the mystery,
that is beauty.
Ben spent four years
separated from his child
due to co-parenting issues.
restraining orders
and challenges navigating
the family court.
But he also experienced shame
from not being able
to see his daughter daily,
guilt because he was absent
and embarrassment because he was unable
to spend time with his daughter
on a consistent basis.
Now it is imperative to note
that as we stand here today,
that through prior relationships
men learn to love and hate.
Some of us have limited
experience with love.
Therefore, relationships
that emphasize self-love
play an essential role in the work we do.
Lifelong relationships
are integral to our efforts,
with specific emphasis
on an individual's ability
to mirror new behavior and connections.
Now, while many fathers like Ben
come to our agency
through social service agencies
and correctional facilities,
many of them come to us
through word of mouth.
They come to our clinic
and can work one-on-one
with a licensed therapist and coach.
A team of individuals
that provide guidance,
advocacy and mentorship.
We also offer group therapy.
In groups of five to 25 fathers or more,
they share stories about their children
and comfort one another
as they work to achieve a common goal.
They hear stories of triumph and struggle
and pour into one another
whenever there is a need.
Together, we ensure
that fathers are mentally
and emotionally prepared
to be in their children's lives.
And when their father
has achieved his goal,
he is invited to come back
and be an ambassador
and pay it forward.
And last but not least,
we ensure that mental health providers,
universities and institutions
have the tools they need to engage fathers
wherever they are throughout the world,
through our online
and in-person instruction.
(Applause)
We work with fathers
as long as they need us.
Or, in other words, until they fire us.
(Laughter)
Now there is no easy formula here.
Every dad is different.
Every kid is different.
Every story is different.
But there are a few things
we do every time.
We are loving our fathers
and the fatherless back to life.
(Applause)
We hug our fathers.
We celebrate them on birthdays
and holidays with a call
to let them know how much
we appreciate them.
And we assume that they have
the power to achieve their goals.
We are a consistent
source of support for them
as they work to process the mistakes
they've made in the past.
For the last few years, we’ve served
over 10,000 fathers in their families.
(Applause)
We've seen fathers accomplish goals,
such as gaining shared custody
of their children,
loving themselves again
and gaining a newfound appreciation
for everything they have
experienced in their life.
All of our fathers enter our doors
feeling hopeless.
But when they leave,
over 90 percent of them say
they have an improved sense of identity
and self-worth.
We've helped fathers
released from jail and prison
return home with their worth,
their dignity and their self-respect.
(Applause)
And of course,
our work just doesn't benefit fathers.
It's for the kids too.
A kid blaming himself for something
he doesn't understand.
The kid like I was, who struggled
and who didn't understand
that fathers are human too.
My father's absence inspired me to create
a safe haven for fathers nationwide.
And truth be told,
my father is currently leading
a life separated from me
as we speak today.
Unfortunately, it is not a perfect ending.
But it is an important one.
It sheds light on the fact
that fathers hurt too.
And it is our responsibility to love them
back to life whenever the need exist.
As I stand on the stage,
I can't stop thinking
about my seven-year-old son, Clayton,
and my one-year-old daughter,
SaMya Grace.
The other day, I asked Clayton,
"What kind of father am I?"
He looked at me and said,
"Um, you have a mustache,"
(Laughter)
"Long hair," this was before
the haircut, may I add.
(Laughter)
"And even a new computer."
I was like, "OK, this is true, son."
He goes on to say,
"I love it when you buy me games,"
before hugging me --
(Laughter)
And running back to his room.
And SaMya Grace.
Every time I ask her for a kiss,
she puckers up her lips and she runs
to kiss me with an enormous smile.
That makes my day every time.
When moments like these occur,
I understand that I have
the privilege to be present,
unlike many of the fathers that walk
through our doors for the first time.
Like them, I am far from perfect.
Despite my mistakes,
my greatest achievement
is being Clayton and SaMya's father.
(Applause)
Millions of fathers today,
regardless of their location,
can say the same thing.
I must admit,
if it had not been
for the individuals in my life
that reminded me of how valuable I was,
I would not be here today.
I'm more than thankful for them
that they loved me back to life.
Fathers that have been absent,
regardless of their past mistakes,
deserve a lifeline.
And if we are deserving,
so are the ones who have lost their way.
Take a moment with me.
Fifteen seconds.
And I'll keep the time.
Think about the people who loved you
when you lost your way.
Who huged you when you needed it.
Who assumed best intention.
Who validated you.
And embraced you
even when you felt undeserving.
Whoever came to mind,
try, just try and be that to someone else.
Thank you.
(Applause)